[Music]
I'm told that you like to make unusual
craft projects and I and I heard about
this and I thought I've got to ask you
about it because it you know and and you
shouldn't judge a book by it's cover but
it seems so unusual I see you you're
such a beautiful woman and I heard about
this craft project it seemed a little
unusual yeah here's a way to alienate
people that's what I do should open with
that yeah yeah I I was living in Texas
for a little while and I started
collecting owl pellets and for anyone
who doesn't know when an owl eats a
field mouse or a rodent it eats it
digests all of the edible parts and then
regurgitates a pellet which is like all
the bones all the undigestible matter
and I collect those and harvest the
bones and then make magical creatures
that's fine with me about that al I
don't give a hoot
yeah yeah
I don't think you should you should I
think you should Hawk show ya you should
be right in liquor store breeding third
[Laughter]
you really do this what would make you
think of this in the first place you saw
you saw an owl pellet you took it apart
and you extract the bones and then you
make art out of it yeah so you're like a
serial killer that's probably on an FBI
profile list somewhere I found some
roadkill on the side of the road one day
and was looking up how to dissolve the
meat in the way that would be like lease
odious to my landlord and neighbors and
one of the early indicators of Jeffrey
Dahmer's I caught the V so it is a yeah
love that she rents I know doing this in
a rental yeah number-one rule for being
a serial killer
don't rent on the basement you got to
own the crawl up to that okay hey let me
ask you this did you ever toss a
prostitute off a bridge
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
I don't think you should host Late Late
Show I think you should take my slot
because I am vacating it I believe you
should drop over there's an opening here
at the Conan show I was just saying I
heard that was a sign of being a serial
killer okay surely the worst guy I've
ever met I mean that in a nice way
all right there's no there's no way to
good guy there's no way to transition
but we have a clip here from halt and
catch fire
yeah and we're just gonna soldier on
here tell us a little bit about your
role I Cameron how she's sort of an
outsider punk prodigy programmer and
sure and she is being scouted by Joe
Macmillan who's played by Lee pace to
sort of come and work for a company that
he is setting up right and you two have
a past no we have a future Wow
let's take a look at this clip from halt
and catch fire you know I screwed him
right
let's be adult about this I'm talking
down to me don't you look there are a
thousand other engineers we can get
preferably one you haven't bedded down
with who are you again I'm the guy who
figured out the boot code in four days
what have you done you heard him a
thousand other engineers no you need me
otherwise you wouldn't be here what do
you want I want you to go dangle your
little opportunity in someone else's
face
[Applause]
[Music]
good never
[Applause]